okay so i just don't know how you did
this with just vanessa and colt
but next week on part two we see that
vanessa appears and her and jess are
just going at it it's what can you tell
me
what can i tell you something i was like
okay and vanessa
you're gonna i'm not obviously i'm not
gonna give anything away
but it's a shocker oh really it's a
shocker i'm like
what wait man where did that come from
it's something more than what we already
know because you know cult dished
his news in part one of the tell-all
that
you know they've been continuing
whatever they had
is it more to that more there's more to
that
story that is going to be shocking
wow wow that's what i will say
more to the story how do you prepare how
do you get ready for these
big moments well um
it's a lot it's it's a lot that goes
into it
um obviously you know i
see the entire season um
before all of you guys see it so
you know when the producers have edited
it all together
they send it to me and so i'm viewing
all of the episodes
um and so it's that and also i know a
lot of the couples from doing these
tell-alls
for so many years so i know their
backstory
and so it's about you know the producers
and i
have uh our sessions where we go over
all the questions that we want to ask
we want to find out obviously what the
audience wants to know
keep in mind though when we are doing
the tell-alls
you have not seen all of the episodes so
there might be something that happens
later on
yes really yes something that happens
later on
that you might wonder oh i wonder why
that wasn't incorporated into this
show but so the way we do the tell-alls
um and we like i said we have a certain
schedule
in terms of when we do them but it goes
into
what we try to find out is what the
audience wants to know
and what we feel is most important
for uh that particular couple when we
started doing this virtually
i thought gosh this is not going to be
as interesting i said because you know
we're not on the studio
people aren't going to be able to walk
off they're not you know they're not
going to really confront each other
oh sister let me tell you
when you're behind the camera you got
all kind of nerve to say anything you
want
to anybody okay i was like what
is happening like they're going off and
you're gonna you're gonna see in this
tell-all
somebody goes off on
angela okay now you know
in person you would not go on right
right behind behind your your
your webcam oh you've got
that when we see angela throw the
computer or whatever she
did and walked off no i think that was a
different time that's
something else well it's so interesting
you say that because
when i watched part one of the tell-all
at the top
people were just throwing insults at
each other back to back and i was like
wow no one has a filter
no one you know most tells you get the
drama like that but this was intense
yes what was your thought overall on
part one
of part one well obviously we want
people to be animated during their
conversations
and we want them to talk about the
things
that they've been talking about all
season because here's what happens a lot
of times
when they get on set and they
you know they meet the person meet
another couple for the first time
sometimes they don't really want to talk
about the things that they've
actually been saying about each other so
you want them to be
honest okay now when it goes off the
rails
you've got to you really have to bring
it back in because then nobody's getting
the information that they need
and you know when folks once again when
folks are
you know at home and they've got they're
in front of their computer
they're just i mean they're just going
off
literally and so it it is real you just
have to
you have to let people say what they
want but then you have to reel them back
in
and let's say okay let's have a
conversation what is this about
all right well do you have a favorite or
craziest tell-all
moments from this three-part special yes
from this three-part
special yes yes
um and i try listen i
try to be um as
as i don't want to play favorites i try
to be as neutral as possible
because that's my role as the host
of the show um
but this we're going to get into
a storyline um
[Music]
you know in part two and i just wanted
like there's somebody i just wanted to
say you know what
like what is wrong with you yes
like literally what is wrong with you
and i just
if i had been there in person i don't
know what i don't know what i would have
done
but it's you know
i i just felt like you really
somebody i'm just not understanding i'm
just really not understanding what
is is their motive for doing what
they're going to be doing
okay well without saying their name
what's the piece of advice you would
give them
can you tell me that and we could play
the guessing game here
what piece of advice would i give them i
think you have to
evaluate whether this is a relationship
that should you should be in
um okay that could be a lot of people i
know there could be a lot of people
right
it could be a lot of people yeah but
we'll i'll try to piece it together i'm
so glad you said the neutral part though
how you have to stay neutral
because i think a lot of viewers if they
don't understand
your role they they question that you
know and they want you to study
different things or do more but that's
not your job
yes and so you know um this this
show there are
99
of the people that watch this franchise
they watch it they enjoy it and they
kind of go
about their lives okay then there there
is another you know smaller percentage
that it's it really consumes
more of their lives than everybody else
okay
so we have you know and they can be very
vocal
about what they and it's never about
what they like
it's always about what they don't like
and
there are you know there are those
people that
i mean listen you know i feel sometimes
i really feel
for the couples who are on the show
because they have to make their social
media private
because they get the [ __ ] for y'all
that they get um is
is you know uncalled for
unnecessary and it it borders
on i mean you we've had some situations
where
you know people have even you know
said things that we had to get law
enforcement and wow
okay so there is that segment
okay so i
you know i know what my role is as the
host and somebody might say oh you need
to
you know you need to you know tear them
a new one or you need to
you know get in it that's not my role
and as a matter of fact
if i and there's always a producer in my
ear
while i am doing the show and
if i sound as though
i'm you know being a little too
hard on somebody you know they will say
okay sean you know
okay you may have a personal opinion
about it but pull back a little bit
and that you know and and so my role
is to be the type of moderator
that the network wants for this show
right and so um and and it's so funny to
me
when people say um oh how come you
didn't ask this
okay we listen we we tape
the tell-all i mean we've had taping
sessions that have lasted
16 hours okay
and so you're seeing a small
percentage of when he actually
take so if somebody says to me how come
you did not ask
this i will always say to them you don't
know what i ask
right you just see what it's produced
but they don't have that understanding
they don't have that understanding of
television you know right
and so and then and then there
are things that happen after
taping okay that
you know someone might say oh how come
you didn't ask about this
well it happened after taping so we you
know we obviously can't ask
about that so it's it's funny to me
when somebody says oh how come you
didn't ask as though they're the only
person who thought of that question
[Laughter]
i didn't think of it the producers
didn't think of it nobody this whole
team
did not think of that question okay
right you're the only one
so it's um you know and sometimes like
if people are courteous about it they'll
say hey sean you know love
i love the show love you i just wanted
to know
why you didn't ask this and i'll explain
and they'll go oh
okay i get it um and then like i said
then there are the folks who are
just you know you go you want to be me
i'm like black girl i ain't got nobody
i love that well you've sat with this
cast before
well some of them in preview right
who do you see the most growth from
whether it's a couple
or an individual anybody
that's a good question let's see the
most
growth from well okay now getting back
to the question that you asked me
about um what advice
would i give it goes back to that
question
because there is somebody that i want to
say
do you really think this is the
relationship that you need to be in
now if i tell you who i see the most
growth fund
from that would give away that
answer because i think this person
may be at the point where they're saying
[Music]
i already know who you're talking about
might not kalani
i think so is it is it either kalani or
elizabeth because those are the two
where i'm just like
girl how do you do it
okay you're gonna stay neutral that's
your job so i appreciate you stopping
before i let you go one last question
you've kind of teased here and there a
bit but
part part two and part three of the
tell-all what can we expect if you could
just give us a tease in one sentence
just wrap it up what could it be
in one sentence oh hard i don't want to
do that for you
but sentence okay the title is going to
see
more on colts
and jessica's story that is
shocking you're going to hear
of more about the family dynamic of
kalani and asuelu and
you are going to have some more
surprises
okay okay crazy surprises
it's always a crazy surprise that's all
yeah it's a 90-day beyonce so it's
always a crazy surprise